thank you to Surf sharkk VPN for
supporting this PBS video let's say you
and your friend meet at a cafe on a hot
day your friend drove in their air
conditioned car while you decided to get
some exercise and bike the 3 miles you
show up sweaty and out of breath and you
both order an ice cold lemonade the
waiter takes one look at you and informs
you that the lemonade will cost twice as
much for you as it will for your friend
pretty unfair right if you're thinking
they can't do that actually they can't
unless they discriminate by certain
protected categories like race gender
age sexual orientation or disability
sellers are legally free to charge
different prices to different people
it's called personalized pricing or
discriminatory pricing and it's a way to
juice profits by extracting the maximum
that people are willing to pay of course
if they did that out in the open like
that customers would probably be so
offended they boycott the place but when
it comes to online shopping there's no
easy way to know whether the price
you're shown is the same for everyone
[Music]
else personalized pricing is actually as
old as Commerce itself for much of human
history most goods were customade if you
were an artisan hired to make something
you would weigh the complexity of the
job the cost of the materials and the
pocket depth of your client before
quoting a price but ever since the
Industrial Revolution Mass manufacturing
of identical products and the emergence
of large retail outlets like department
stores have normalized the idea of
standardized pricing it wasn't until the
late 19th century that department store
Pioneer John Wanamaker implemented the
use of price tags a nail in the coffin
for the ancient tradition of haggling
that's not to say we're not a accustomed
to some forms of dynamic pricing we know
that an airline ticket will cost more
the day of the flight and a hotel room
will cost more during tourist season we
know about Uber surges and senior
discounts and we know that when we walk
into a car lot the salesman will exploit
observations about our income and
urgency to squeeze as much money out of
us as he can but when it comes to
Everyday retail items we've come to
expect that everyone should pay the same
price that may be changing thanks to
technology as you probably already know
data trackers follow you relentlessly
around cyberspace monitoring what you
read what you watch and most importantly
what you buy they remember how many
times you looked at that sweater and how
long your mouse hovered over the add to
cart button all of this personal info
and behavior is analyzed by an algorithm
that can not only guess what products
you'd like but what you'd be willing to
pay for them it's like if the the
salesman at the car dealership knew
everything about you the moment you
walked onto the lot Defenders of price
discrimination argue that it can lead to
a more efficient market even though some
people will see higher prices others
will see lower prices allowing them to
buy things they otherwise wouldn't be
able to afford for example price
discrimination in college tuition allows
universities to offer lowincome students
scholarships and grants subsidized by
the high tuition paid by wealthier
students and there are studies that show
that some forms of discriminatory
pricing result in higher overall
customer satisfaction after all in
theory everyone's paying what they think
is a fair price but only when the
participants don't know about it as soon
as they found out that different people
were paying different prices the
majority thought the system was unfair
as a paper from Seattle University puts
it if a transaction satisfies a customer
only because of a lack of trans
transparency one cannot claim that it
increases utility these justifications
aside there's only one reason a for
profit company would be interested in
discriminatory pricing it maximizes
profits we're all familiar with a
standard demand curve which illustrates
the higher you set your price the fewer
people will buy your product with
standardized pricing sellers want to
find the highest number that won't scare
away too many potential customers but no
matter how hard they try to strike that
balance there will always be some
customers who would have paid more that
Gap is known as consumer surplus
consumer surplus feels great it's that
warm fuzzy feeling you get when the
pleasure of a purchase outweighs the
cost like the saying goes everyone loves
a bargain except not everyone sellers
hate consumer surplus to them that's
money left on the table in a perfect
world every customer would pay the
absolute most they'd be willing to pay
so that no one ever feels like they got
a good deal this is the end goal of
discriminatory pricing it's also
important to remember that willingness
to pay does not always correlate with
wealth some customers might tolerate
high prices not because they can afford
it but because they're desperate or have
few other options grocery stores in
low-income neighborhoods for instance
can charge more than those in wealthy
neighborhoods because they know the
local have less flexibility to drive
around looking for the best deal
discriminatory pricing also violates the
principle of informational symmetry in
Classic Market Theory fair prices are
set when the parties to the transaction
have similar levels of knowledge but
while online sellers know everything
about us we rarely know anything about
them we don't really know how much these
products are worth what they cost to
manufacture or how big their profit mark
margins are and we certainly don't know
what their minimum willingness to charge
is in fact the only leverage we usually
have is knowing what other people are
paying but in the atomized world of the
internet where we each inhabit a unique
isolated bubble even that knowledge is
hidden and the Battle of information
between consumers and companies
consumers are at a huge disadvantage
discriminatory pricing is still in an
experimental stage with many online
retailers interested but not quite ready
to pull the trigger perhaps out of fear
of customer anger still on some sites
you might see lower prices if you use
your mobile device instead of a laptop
or a Windows PC instead of a Mac for
some reason they think MacBook users
have money to burn you can also try
using a private browser to do your
browsing so the algorithm won't catch
you gazing longingly at that mid-century
modern shoe Hutch and some customers
report getting lower prices is by
visiting competitor sites first a signal
that you're a smart customer another way
for consumers to work around
discriminatory pricing is through
Arbitrage the buying of goods where
demand is low and reselling where demand
is high in this case customers offered
low prices can resell them to customers
who are only offered high prices however
any good algorithm will be able to spot
such entrepreneurs and adjust prices
accordingly as more companies use
artificial intelligence to navigate
their pricing strategies we may see a
world where prices are constantly
fluctuating based on everything from the
weather to your mood what you had for
breakfast that morning one experiment
even found that competing pricing
algorithms figured out how to cooperate
to keep prices High just by observing
and reacting to each other's strategies
in the real world such price fixing is
flat out illegal but is it considered
collusion when there are no humans
involved D consumers still disapprove of
personalized pricing by a wide margin
and that may be enough to scare away
retailers for the time being but as our
shopping experiences become more and
more personalized consumers may have to
fight back by just communicating with
each other about what we think things
should cost and that's our two cents
thank you to Surf shark bpn for
supporting this PBS video surf shark bpn
is a virtual private Network design
design to keep your online identity safe
by encrypting all of the information
sent between your device and the
internet using a VPN when on public
Wi-Fi can help provide safety while
surfing the internet as well as working
from home a lot of online services use
sophisticated targeting and tracking
services but a VPN can provide
protection from that surf shark's clean
web feature is built to block ads
trackers malware and fishing attempts
and if you do a lot of international
traveling surf shark allows clients to
change their virtual location it has
over 3200 servers in more than 100
countries designed to help make sure you
can access your home countryes features
while traveling to learn more click the
link in the description thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
Patron for more about how your online
shopping habits are monitored check out
our video how retailers St talk you
[Music]
online